[Music]
we've been hearing about America's
opioid crisis for years according to the
Centers for Disease Control on average a
hundred and thirty Americans die every
day from an opioid overdose an explosive
new Netflix documentary series shows how
a Louisiana pharmacist was forced to
face the crisis head-on and reveal some
stunning facts about its origins Jami
wax is here with this story Jami good
morning good morning Jeff the pharmacist
profiles Louisiana father Dan Schneider
he was one of the first to discover and
battle what we now know as the opioid
crisis after a tragic personal loss made
him determined to help others he gave us
exclusive access to a story now riveting
viewers across the nation I really felt
like I had no other choice ahead to find
my son's killer trivedi when Dan
Snyder's son Danny jr. was murdered in
an area rife with crime and an apparent
crack deal in 1999 his sense of
helplessness sent him searching for
answers but you know he didn't want this
to happen he was a good-natured kid he
surely wasn't daddy blaming himself and
I know him the incredible true story of
Snyder's tenacious hunt for justice and
the discoveries he later made are the
subject of the new Netflix documentary
series the pharmacist Dan Schneider
I'm a pharmacist I guess some people
would call me obsessive if you want to
call it that in other news a st. Bernard
family is on a campaign for justice
Snyder traveled again and again from his
home in Louisiana st. Bernard Parish to
the Lower Ninth Ward of New Orleans at
the time arguably the most dangerous
neighborhood in the country is begging
for help in finding his son's killer
this man is surely gonna get killed if
he keeps walking around this
neighborhood asking question oh
definitely because I thought that was a
great recipe for him to get killed
Reverend Terrence Reid ran a
rehabilitation program at a church in
the area and I thought we had a great
program and I thought we can help
families and I was crazy I thought I can
change the world and I've met someone
else that thought the same thing and I
saw in his mind said that he had a dis
conviction that nothing wasn't gonna
stop if I were to say no he was going
back out there anyway how the reader
said you know mr. Schneider will walk
the streets with you we'll go house to
house and we'll let you ask the
questions and we'll be there with you it
gave me some credibility not only gave
me safety but some of the people who saw
black people walking with me bought into
in terms of I get it my efforts on the
street paid off with a conviction
16-year juvenile was the actual trigger
person in this in this homicide but
after getting justice for his son a new
mystery landed on his doorstep with a
different trust and a different dealer I
ran a promo to find out how many
oxycontin prescriptions we were filling
that Bradley's and when I ran this day
and I looked at the paperwork going
it was a routine Schneider was on a new
crusade to save young people's lives
from the opioid problem that was only
just beginning to ravage his community
what is being here at this place mean to
you oh well I want to do is show the
reality of what families go through the
cemetery is filled with a lot of young
people that have died from this opiate
epidemic and that's that's what I saw
happened what he was right some longtime
friends of Snyder's are also featured in
the series including former st. Bernard
Parish Sheriff Jack Stevens and
prominent Louisiana lawyer Walter Lachey
I've never seen anybody do anything of
this nature and seem to have run into a
number of roadblocks of members of law
enforcement federally and locally you
know kind of getting is wet but it
didn't deter him Lachey is currently
representing the state in its lawsuit
against the drug companies Danny's
battle was about was a very local battle
involving a particular manufacturer
Perdue manufacturing oxycontin which was
people have alleged abusively marketing
to doctors this doctor took advantage of
it and and illegally ultimately
prescribed opioid drugs Snyder's
relentless campaign to shut down dr.
Jacqueline Clegg its operation using his
only recordings and surveillance footage
was ultimately successful today while we
were sitting here doing this interview
is ten years to the day that you got her
practice shut down so you know I felt a
great deal of satisfaction but the world
never really knew what I did know the
same thing uh police knew and you know
quietly they gave me credit okay FBI
with nothing dollars I did anything pa
would never knowledge it to anything if
you're a guy in Dad's situation it's
hard to have a high degree of confidence
in the police I was Sheriff for 28 years
I can't tell you that I saved one life
but I can tell you this I know dance
night I stayed hundreds if not thousands
of lives
Snyder's wife Annie says her late son
would be grateful for his father's fight
what do you think Danny would think of
all this that's at
right now I think he would really be
proud of his daddy that to go forward
with his mission that he wanted to do
and help other people that have problems
with drugs and and get into like rehab
and not educate the people educate
parents and children in schools the
Netflix series is bringing a whole new
level of attention and recognition to
Schneider and that's ok with him as long
as it helps him shine a light on the
real and continuing issue and now I have
a spotlight if you want to call it light
it's all about light and hope some of
them are you through the tunnel no I'm
not exactly thrilled the tunnels but I
can see light ice can see light and
hopefully I had almost lost that hope
I'm sure you ever get out of that tunnel
complete with the story yeah a lot of
people were shedding my a lot of the
feds were going in and shutting down
these pill mills but they were doing it
in african-american communities and ours
seeing sort of like in the suburban
areas where it was needed as well yeah
and you don't really have to her he was
10 years ahead of everyone yeah he saw
it he knew it in these kids eyes he said
he saw his son in the eyes of these
young people that were coming and
putting these prescriptions across his
desk yes that sheriff said saved
hundreds if not thousands it's
incredible great story Jamie thanks
thanks Jimmy